as you can see here using these um tree
diagrams becomes a bit of a hassle like
do I really have to do this it's a very
time-consuming process it's physically
difficult so instead the tool that
you'll see that will dominate this is
much simpler instead we'll just draw a
box and this box has a bunch of slots in
it that we fit all of the different
items into so for example I'm interested
in just three letters right so I've got
three boxes three positions to put
letters into and I'm going to state all
the same information over here but in a
much more concise form for the first
spot here this is the first example with
repetition right I've got three choices
for that first letter a B or C if I
allow repetition when I go to the next
letter
how many choices do I have still three
three choices and then the last time
nothing has changed I've still loud
repetitions so I'm getting three choices
right now to combine all of these
together what am I going to do I am
going to multiply each step but the key
that I'm trying to get across to you why
I want us to draw these tree diagrams
and make a point of it is you can see
why it is multiplication right and not
addition because each time your branch
is a branching out further and further
and further so that gives you the three
cubed with repetition and in exactly the
same way if I now consider the situation
without repetition without replacement
as it were I'm still gonna have three
slots but the choice has changed right
I've start off with three then I start
to whittle them down as I make the
choices right in the last one you've
only got one choice left so that gives
you that 3 factorial without repetition
okay now one last quick example before
we generalize this and then add a little
bit of a teeny little bit of new
notation for you right this is where you
consider an audit selection where the
order of your items matter a permutation
where you've got the same length of you
know your list as the number of items on
your list right well what if I changed
it he's a new color here's a new example
for you instead of making a three-letter
word out of three letters say for
example I made a a two letter word it's
not really going to be a word I guess
but mathematicians would use this just
to have any string of letters together a
two letter word with the whole alphabet
right so we've got a through Z to choose
from now you can see in a situation like
this you don't want to draw the tree
diagram for this do you like you'll
start drawing and then the Sun will set
and you'll think I've got better things
to do with my time right so instead
we're going to do this little simple
structure here I'm gonna draw my box how
many different slots will there be in my
box
just two right because you are choosing
our first letter and a second letter and
tada there is your two that'll work okay
now let's do it for both if we've got
repetition allowed repetition allowed I
will have how many choices for the first
letter 26 choices and here on the loud
repetition so when I go for my second
letter it's still 26
so what's this going to equal well I'm
multiplying as I go left to right so
this is 26 squared this is with
repetition and if I said without no
repetition allowed without replacement
as it were how many choices do I have
for my first letter 26 I haven't picked
out any but having selected that first
letter now one is out of the running so
for my second letter I only have 25
choices there okay now in this case
because I'm not choosing you know
Twitter sweet six letter word there
aren't many of those I guess in the
dictionary I can't just say 26 factorial
can I in the same way that I don't say
26 to the power of 26 so here I have 26
x 25 but I can actually write this in
factorial notation let me show you how
right if I wrote 26 factorial it'll be
26 times 25 times 24 23 22 etc right so
in other words the ones that I'm missing
24 23 22 etcetera okay so if I added
them back on but then I said I actually
don't want to include them right I would
have to divide by all of those
factorials to get them to cancel out
from the original number right and the
ones that I want to get rid of are 24 23
22 21 etcetera that's 24 factorial okay
now can you see where this expression
here comes from in terms of the original
question right one more way that I can
state this is to say that this factorial
notation down here it comes from the
original number that you started with
right how many you have to choose from
bless you and then this number down the
bottom right you take all of those that
you had to choose from but you subtract
the number that you are going to select
you're only going to select two of them
right that gives me my 24 factorial now
this guy down here the reason why I've
highlighted in you color this is what
we're going to be using over and over
again because this is the most
common situation that we're dealing with
right you often don't want to select all
of the people you just want to select a
particular number out of many many
different choices okay
so this guy down here is the main kind
of permutation that you will see without
replacement because we often are dealing
with physical objects like people or
whiteboard markers doesn't like that so
this guy down here gets a new form of
notation and one that will look
remarkably similar remarkably familiar
rather certain we write it as 26 P 2
that P stands for permutation okay so
now I'm ready to tell you what does
permutation mean well if you have a look
at the word it sort of gives you some
clues right when we think like in
biology in evolutionary terms right
what's a mutation does that mean when
something is mutated to to mutate like a
you know it's like whoa this bird has
like cool of feathers than the previous
generation right there's been a change
that's been introduced that's what
mutation means right there's a change
that's what the mutation part of
permutation means the perm part which we
get from permanent or permeate it means
you can change everything all the way
through you don't just change the
feathers you know just change like how
big the muscles are of this animal some
like that you can change anything you
can change all of these different
choices right so to permute something
needs to go through every single item
and then change all of the different
spots what they can be equal to right so
that's literally what permutation means
now this guy here should look familiar
to what kind of notation which topic
it's one which I talked about with the
factorial right this looks just like
this 26 with a see right now we're going
to come to where this is useful in a
couple lessons time but if you have a
look at your calculator I think you'll
find it over in the pork nut borio is
actually it should be over on the right
hand side yeah it's a that's right so if
you have a look above your
multiplication and division buttons
you're going to see these two pieces of
notation here right the calculator
writes them like this because it doesn't
have that much
space is it like that yeah yeah or and
CR now we have used this guy in binomial
theorem right at the moment if we're
going to focus on this guy we're looking
at permutations and this is the way that
you write it just like you did with NCR
notation but we're indicating that all
the matters it's a permutation where ABC
is not the same as CBA okay